-Performing the title track
to the "Marry Me" soundtrack,
give it up for Jennifer Lopez
and Maluma!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I've never seen forever ♪
♪ I've never seen forever
in the wild ♪
♪ But now I'm looking,
now I'm looking in its eyes ♪
♪ Baby, you're my shelter ♪
♪ Shelter from
a broken paradise ♪
♪ I couldn't dream it any better
if I tried ♪
-♪ True love got
a ring, ring, ring ♪
♪ Church bells,
let 'em ring, ring, ring ♪
-♪ You the queen,
I be the king, king, king ♪
-♪ For life, for life,
for life ♪
♪ Marry me, marry me, say yes ♪
♪ For the rest, the rest
of your life ♪
-♪ I'mma fly out to Vegas,
yeah ♪
♪ We could tie it up tonight,
no patience ♪
♪ Take my last name,
put it where your name is ♪
♪ Have they ever seen
a love this famous? ♪
-♪ They never, no, they never ♪
♪ This forever, ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever ♪
♪ Ain't nobody do it better,
better, better ♪
♪ And it's only getting better ♪
-♪ True love got
a ring, ring, ring ♪
-♪ Ooh, we gotta ♪
-♪ Church bells,
let 'em ring, ring, ring ♪
-♪ Ooh, they gotta ♪
♪ This queen need
a king, king, king ♪
-♪ For life, for life,
for life ♪
-♪ For life ♪
-♪ True love got
a ring, ring, ring ♪
-♪ Ring, ring ♪
-♪ Church bells,
let 'em ring, ring, ring ♪
-♪ Ring, ring ♪
-♪ Angels gonna sing,
sing, sing ♪
-♪ Tonight, tonight, tonight ♪
♪ Baby, marry me,
marry me, say yes ♪
♪ Marry me, marry me, say yes ♪
♪ For the rest ♪
-♪ The rest of your life ♪
-♪ Marry me, baby ♪
-♪ Marry me, marry me, say yes ♪
♪ Marry me, marry me, say yes ♪
♪ For the rest, the rest
of your life ♪
-♪ Baby ♪
♪ Si me das tu mano, te lo juro
por mi vida que seré fiel ♪
♪ Y aunque pasen cosas buenas
y cosas malas ♪
♪ Yo siempre estaré ♪
♪ Cuidándote ♪
♪ Un amor eterno te daré ♪
-♪ Ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-
ma-ma-ma-marry me ♪
♪ Won't you love me, baby? ♪
♪ Ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-
ma-ma-ma-marry me ♪
-♪ I want you in my life
so bad ♪
-♪ Ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-
ma-ma-ma-marry me ♪
♪ Won't you love me, baby? ♪
♪ Ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-
ma-ma-ma-marry me ♪
♪ Ahhhhhhhh ♪
♪ Ah-ah-ahhhhhhhhhh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jennifer Lopez! Maluma!
"Marry Me" hits theaters
February 11th.